we have a guest from us anastasia carlos
joining us actually from athens greece
hello nastia
hello everybody it's so great to see you
i'm in greece you're right
how are you enjoying the candidates
uh of i'm enjoying my candidates almost
at the beach you know i just put this
jacket on my swimming suit but no matter
where you are you are watching the
candidates even though i'm in athens now
we have plus 35 degrees i'm very near to
the sea i cannot do anything i have to
stay here and watch the games because
they're so exciting and we have so much
action right
how are you
guys we're
we're not at the beach we're not in our
swimsuits so we we we have issues that
we will like to address later
uh but we we're loving the the the games
we think the players are playing so hard
each and every round the fights
are just what we imagine
those candidates could bring us
anastasia i we don't want to put you on
the spot but what are you seeing so far
from these players which player is uh
taking your attention
yeah it's really it's very difficult to
judge at the moment we still have the
round number four at the moment uh but
what i can say from now that of course i
mean somehow yan shows quite uh self
confident play and um i'm really a
little bit afraid that if he wins this
candidate magnus will say i don't want
to play this match
this is i really worry at the moment so
um i don't know let's see how it goes
but at the moment uh jan looks
the best at this moment but everything
can change you know i've seen uh i've
been to almost every candidate's
tournament uh not like maurice ashley
who just said yesterday that it's his
first one actually i think it's a second
one which i'm missing since uh 2013 and
i've seen that sometimes
things can change so dramatically after
the middle of the tournament i remember
aranyan who played very well in london
suddenly started to play differently on
the second half of the candidates so we
have seen different examples
but
it looks interesting so far
well guys let's keep one of the boards
open on nepo's game we do have a bunch
of moves at night
they will come very quickly right so let
us see if there's a way to have nasty
here join us in the conversation because
network game is so crucial for the
standings and it's moving quickly yeah
and i just saw this knight you know like
land on the square b2 and it was just
like kind of uh amusing to me that uh
after
uh the move rook f4
queen e2 i i mean i'm assuming that uh
um
nepo has set up a trap he's made his
thing
i think you just take i think with the
queen
queenie why am i doing with the queen
okay can you think with the bishops it's
easier
it's sure enough
and
well you can't take the pawn because of
bishop and knight v2 and i just thought
that is
that is very very funny uh
i
what do you think of this move knight v2
yeah i mean so it's an interesting move
but i really don't want to be on a live
in malireza's seat right now i mean it's
really unpleasant position to play i
think he understands that things are not
going well at this moment so he's just
trying you know to find some tricks to
still stay in the game
35 seconds now
what do you think about the time control
for these candidates no increment how do
you feel about that yes how do you feel
it affects their play
yes it's always like that and it's a
very unique tournament with this uh time
controller remember of course vasily
vancouver lost five games in london uh
just because of this time control when
you don't have increment it's really
different uh game right you have to take
care of your time so much and
i think it affects a little bit the
players and the result maybe actually
that's why yanni policy has some
advantage because we know how fast he
used to play and
how fast he uh makes his decisions so i
don't know what do you think would you
like to play with this time control or
not
no i i think the players are used as you
just said uh to the increment
and when they don't have the increment
they often
[Music]
uh get tasered yeah they flounder a
little bit and you can see that alareza
i mean he's left himself literally five
seconds per move from here until time
control and he has actually how many
seven or yeah seven seven more moves 35
seconds
i remember this whole times when i
played like maybe 15 moves in 13 seconds
but
you better don't go for this right 15
moves in 13 seconds yeah yes one time
and for this league i just have managed
to do something like that
going to remind me not to challenge you
in any bullet games
how many pieces did you lose in the
process
and you imagine they even won the game
but uh the tip our captain of the team
had heart attack of course you can
imagine
yes exactly now uh unfortunately for uh
ali reza he's searching for cheapos he's
played this move knight b2
and unfortunately for
for alireza he's playing against a guy
nepo
who loves he thrives on such moments
where he can play literally move for
move he's not going to let you think
for the next seven seconds or something
and he's blitzing down to 17 seconds i
assume the move even rook takes h7
must win right that could win you know
what's really a cheeky move
rook goes back to f4
you were just on f4 but you played f6
thank you so much right
to block the diagonal okay you're just
having too much fun right now wow
[Laughter]
wow
natasha uh final thoughts uh
who is your predicted winner right now
with
round four underway
uh of course i'm rooting for fabiano
caruana because if he plays really well
i have my chance to go to madrid maybe
and follow the tournament from there so
of course i'm rooting for him so he's my
ticket to
madrid you can imagine
[Laughter]
congratulations to alejandro who has
birthday today we have a birthday boy in
the studio so alejandra all the best for
you very much thank you i've seen many
comments people keep uh sending you
messages yes lovely you know it'll be a
tough day for my phone thank you for uh
breaking away from the beach uh as
compelling as it sounds and joining us
always a pleasure to see you
thank you so much for joining us
and we have a couple of updates